I I I know I'm not a doctor yeah I don't
I've heard
sorry it is inside
I could be Ken yeah
yeah so um I'm not a you know main guy
but um what exactly is what's going on
there sorry you've got veins going down
your colon so you see it sometimes it
pops out of this yeah it pops out you
got to push it back up a vein no yeah
half your anus yeah you push it back up
and you just move on with your day
that's all you can do it's embarrassing
if you're jamming your butthole inside
your butthole is it embarrassing well
only if you do it in front of people
yeah but in the car you're even like
hugs no no no it's not like I I
like sneeze and then go
oh you know so I eat those specifics
after a yeah it happens you just
push it back up and you move on yeah